Boa tarde a todos.
Eu hoje venho falar-vos sobre Guimarães,
como podem ver na imagem
e o meu objetivo é, principalmente,
fazer uma reflexão sobre Guimarães.
Queria, de certa forma,
inspirar-vos e inspirar esta cidade.
Queria, também, fazer um desafio que,
a meio da apresentação, irão perceber.
Guimarães é uma cidade
relativamente pequena
com cerca de 158 mil habitantes.
Eu nasci aqui, nesta cidade.
Eu cresci nesta cidade.
Estudei nesta cidade.
Fiz muitas amizades...
Criei a minha empresa aqui,
em Guimarães,
uma agência de "marketing".
E aprendi muito ao longo destes anos.
Neste momento, eu trabalho
numa empresa chamada Prozis
que é uma empresa que vende
suplementos alimentares.
O meu cargo é de direção de "marketing",
ou seja, trabalho
há já alguns anos nesta área,
onde pude aprender muito
sobre negócios em geral
e também aprendi muito sobre "marketing",
sobre desenvolvimento de marcas,
desenvolvimento de produtos,
vendas,...
Mas, principalmente,
sobre negócios "online".
Em Guimarães, como disse,
temos cerca de 158 mil habitantes
e estas pessoas trabalham,
maioritariamente,
nas mais de 6 mil empresas que existem cá.
Queria fazer uma pergunta:
quem é que daqui é de Guimarães?
Pode pôr o braço no ar?
Ok, muita gente.
E já que falamos de negócios,
quem é que de vocês conhece alguém
que tenha uma empresa
ou que tem negócios?
Ok, muito bem.
E quem é que conhece alguém
que tem negócios "online"?
Ou uma loja "online"?... Alguém conhece?
Ok, já são menos alguns...
E quem é que, de vocês,
faz regularmente compras "online"?
Ou já fez alguma vez?
Ok, bastantes pessoas.
Muito bem.
Então, se vocês fazem compras "online",
provavelmente devem conhecer
uma das maiores lojas do mundo,
que é conhecida por todos...
Quem é que me pode dizer qual é
a loja mais popular no mundo inteiro?
(Várias respostas)
A Amazon, muito bem.
eBay também é,
mas hoje vou falar-vos da Amazon.
A Amazon, para quem não sabe,
é, neste momento, a segunda maior
loja "online" do mundo
a seguir ao Alibaba,
que é uma loja e um "marketplace" chinês.
A Amazon foi fundada há 22 anos,
mais ou menos, em 1994
numa pequena cidade chamada
Bellevue, em Washington, nos EUA..
A Amazon, para quem se recorda
ou, pelo menos,
para quem é da minha idade
começou por vender
livros e CDs na Internet.
Ou seja, na altura, a Amazon
não vendia o que vende hoje em dia,
em que vende tudo e mais alguma coisa...
A Amazon é um autêntico "shopping online"
onde nós podemos comprar de tudo:
comida, eletrodomésticos,
livros, roupa, etc.
"You name it", qualquer coisa,
a Amazon vende.
A Amazon, para além de ser
uma das maiores lojas do mundo,
é um "marketplace",
ou seja, a Amazon é um mercado.
O que é que isto quer dizer?
Quer dizer que a Amazon não só vende
os seus próprios produtos,
mas também permite que outros vendedores
e outras empresas, outros retalhistas
também façam as suas vendas
no seu portal.
Ou seja, isto quer dizer que,
se eu, Rui, tiver uma empresa
eu posso colocar os meus produtos
à venda na Amazon
enviando para os armazéns deles,
em todo o mundo,
e eles podem vender os produtos,
ganhando uma comissão
por cada produto que vendem.
Basicamente, este é o modelo de negócio
do "marketplace" da Amazon.
Só para terem uma ideia,
hoje em dia existem mais de dois milhões
de vendedores e retalhistas
que vendem na plataforma da Amazon.
É qualquer coisa!
Dois milhões de empresas, de retalhistas
que vendem para mais de 300 milhões
de utilizadores ativos,
que fazem compras na Amazon.
Mais de 300 milhões de utilizadores ativos,
é qualquer coisa...
O volume de negócios da Amazon em 2015
foi de cerca de 107 biliões de dólares.
Pouco dinheiro!
O que é que isto tem a ver com Guimarães?
Devem estar vocês a perguntar...
Para mim, tem tudo a ver com Guimarães
e vamos já ver porquê.
Mas, para isso, primeiro vou-vos
contar uma história...
Uma história de uma empresa
que me diz muito...
Uma empresa de Braga
que começou numa pequena lojinha...
Para quem conhece Braga,
ficava na Rua dos Maximinos.
Começou com a ideia
de um empreendedor, chamado Miguel
que eu conheci já vão cerca de dez anos
e ele, na altura, tinha 23 anos apenas...
Ou seja, um jovem com 23 anos
que teve uma ideia de criar uma loja
que vendia produtos biológicos,
produtos orgânicos,
alimentação saudável, por aí fora.
Isto, há dez anos, era uma grande loucura.
Quase ninguém sabia o que era isso
dos produtos biológicos!
Então, o Miguel veio ter comigo e disse:
"Rui, preciso da tua ajuda
para pôr isto a funcionar".
"Ajudar a montar a minha loja,
criar um plano de "marketing",
"fazer publicidade, criar imagem".
E assim foi.
Ajudei o Miguel a fazer a loja.
O Miguel abriu a sua loja
e trabalhou durante alguns meses.
E, mês após mês,
as vendas não estavam a aparecer.
Passado, mais ou menos, um ano
esta loja fechou.
Basicamente, não funcionava.
Provavelmente, este seria um negócio
para este momento.
Ou seja, estava demasiado
à frente do seu tempo
e os clientes não estavam
preparados para isso.
Mas, como tudo na vida,
com o falhanço e com o erro
há sempre uma aprendizagem
e surgem sempre novas oportunidades.
E assim foi.
Neste caso, reza a história
que existia uma pequena prateleira na loja
que, na altura, chamava-se
"Sabores com Saúde".
Uma pequena prateleira
que vendia suplementos alimentares
e que vendia mais que a loja toda.
Estamos a falar de uma loja
que julgo ter cerca de 200m2,
mais ou menos,
e uma pequena prateleira
vendia mais que a loja toda!
É qualquer coisa de extraordinário!
O que é que se passa aqui?
Ele percebeu que havia um mercado,
um nicho que procurava estes produtos.
Então, encheu-se de coragem
e, sem dinheiro nenhum,
tinha-o gasto todo na loja
ao longo daquele ano,
sem dinheiro nenhum, pensou:
"Ok, tenho aqui uma oportunidade, mas
eu preciso de um plano, de uma estratégia"
E foi aí que ele pensou:
"Então, preciso de três coisas."
"Algum dinheiro,
para poder fazer algum investimento
e fazer crescer o meu negócio,
para testar se este funciona."
"Preciso de ter muita contenção
nas minhas despesas fixas,
"porque foi isso
que me levou a este ponto...
"Ou seja, o facto de ter uma loja,
o facto de ter empregados,
"de ter uma série de despesas fixas
que uma loja acarreta
"levou-me a esta situação
"— não vendi o suficiente para conseguir
pagar as minhas despesas."
Então, ele queria um negócio "lean",
com poucas despesas,
com poucos recursos, digamos assim.
E precisava de uma outra coisa também,
que era, precisamente, clientes.
Precisava do máximo de clientes possível
para poder fazer o seu negócio.
Então, foi aí que ele decidiu
fazer uma coisa bastante arriscada:
o Miguel vendeu tudo o que tinha
para começar este negócio.
Vocês estão a ver aqui na fotografia
o carro do Miguel
ou, pelo menos, um carro semelhante
que ele vendeu
para poder montar o seu negócio.
Este rapaz de 23 anos
arrisca tudo o que tinha
para montar um negócio,
depois de ter falhado um muito parecido!
Foi aqui, precisamente,
que nasceu a Prozis,
neste momento em que ele investe tudo
na nutrição desportiva,
na suplementação alimentar.
O Miguel conta, muitas vezes,
uma história gira.
Quando abriu a sua loja,
ainda com muitas dúvidas,
começava a receber as encomendas,
uma a uma, dia após dia,
quase nem queria acreditar que
estava a receber encomendas pela Internet,
naquela altura era algo de muito raro,
digamos assim.
E ele conta que ia uma a uma,
encomenda a encomenda,
de calções e chinelos,
entregar aos CTT.
Chegava lá, entregava a encomenda
e enviava para os clientes.
Isto era algo espetacular
há dez anos atrás!
E hoje em dia, já não é o Miguel
que envia as encomendas.
Temos uma equipa
de dezenas de pessoas
que fazem o "picking"
e o embalamento das encomendas
num armazém que tem mais de 15 mil m2
e que envia milhares de encomendas
para todo o mundo.
Isto só vendendo suplementos alimentares!
Nós não vendemos mais nada.
Vendemos suplementos alimentares.
Além disso, já não é o Miguel
que leva as encomendas aos CTT.
São os CTT que vêm até à nossa empresa,
até ao nosso armazém
que fica na Póvoa de Lanhoso
e, diariamente, chegam carrinhas e camiões
que levam as encomendas para todo o mundo.
E afinal, o que é a Prozis?
A Prozis é, neste momento,
um dos líderes "online"
de venda de suplementos alimentares
em todo o mundo.
Ou seja, um dos líderes mundiais de venda
de suplementos alimentares.
E como é que isto começou?
Isto começou, mais ou menos,
há nove anos atrás
e tem sido, no mínimo,
uma experiência muito interessante.
Em nove anos apenas
nós conseguimos, por exemplo,
neste momento, enviar
mais de quatro mil encomendas diárias
para mais de cem países.
Nós temos, neste momento,
mais de um milhão de clientes
registados na nossa loja
e mais de cinco mil referências
de produtos
que estão constantemente em "stock"
e disponíveis na nossa loja "online".
Já agora, quem é que daqui
conhece a Prozis?
Até tem bastante gente,
pensei que fossem menos!
Muito bem!
Este ano temos uma faturação prevista
de mais de 50 milhões de euros.
Julgo que posso afirmar que é um sucesso
em apenas nove anos termos conseguido
atingir estes números.
Mas este sucesso depende muito
dos nossos 250 colaboradores.
Quando eu conheci o Miguel,
era apenas ele e a esposa
que trabalhavam na empresa.
Neste momento somos mais
de 250 trabalhadores.
E como é que isto foi possível?
Com o trabalho em equipa desta gente toda
para atingir este sucesso
que a Prozis atingiu.
Então, o que é que isto tem a ver
com Guimarães, mais uma vez pergunto eu?
Eu digo que tem tudo a ver com Guimarães.
Vou voltar atrás um bocadinho
e vou lembrar-vos
que falei de Guimarães no início,
mas também falei numa pequena cidade
chamada Bellevue, em Washington
que tem, apenas, 133 mil habitantes.
E, desta cidade pequenina, nasceu
um fenómeno mundial chamado Amazon
que é, hoje em dia, somente
o maior "marketplace" do mundo,
ou um dos maiores "marketplaces" do mundo.
E isto nasceu desta cidade pequenina.
Eu queria lançar-vos um desafio.
Guimarães tem poucos mais habitantes
que Bellevue, em Washington
e Guimarães tem uma das melhores
universidades do mundo também.
É uma cidade muito jovem,
cheia de empresários,
com empresas muito capazes,
que têm produtos extraordinários
que só nós conseguimos produzir
com a qualidade que nós produzimos.
O meu desafio é para todos vocês
que estão aqui nesta plateia.
Eu sei que também devem estar aqui
pessoas da Câmara Municipal,
das associações comerciais,
empresários, empreendedores, etc.
Este desafio é para vocês.
O desafio é criarmos um "marketplace"
para Guimarães
que vende para todo o mundo.
E isto, meus amigos, é possível.
Quem é que acredita que isto é possível?
Preciso de mais força... Não chega!
(Risos)
Muito bem, eu digo-vos
que é possível porquê?
Se a Amazon fez isto em Bellevue,
em Washington,
vocês podem dizer:
"Isto foi possível
porque era nos Estados Unidos...
aquilo é porreiro, muita gente
muito dinheiro...
Sim, é verdade.
Mas, nós aqui em Braga,
aqui ao lado
com pessoas de Braga
e de Guimarães,
que estudaram na Universidade do Minho,
fizemos a Prozis.
Que não é, obviamente, a Amazon
mas é qualquer coisa de extraordinário.
Ainda há poucos anos atrás,
abriu aqui no Avepark
uma plataforma,
um "marketplace" também brutal
que se chama Farfetch.
E a Farfetch conseguiu ser
um dos maiores "marketplaces" do mundo.
Então, isto é possível, meus amigos.
Eu acho que isto é mesmo possível.
A minha proposta é esta:
juntarmo-nos todos
para criarmos um "hub" empresarial,
uma plataforma de vendas "online"
baseada numa forte plataforma logística,
obviamente
— temos de ter um excelente serviço
para entregar ao cliente
senão, não funciona...
e desenvolvida por uma equipa de "experts"
— e acreditem que nós temos "experts"
também em Guimarães.
Eu posso ser um deles, por exemplo...
(Risos)
E isto é possível, nós fazermos
um "hub" empresarial
que desenvolva todo este projeto
e que permita
que as empresas de Guimarães,
os empresários, as lojas, etc.
façam vendas para todo o mundo,
para milhões de consumidores.
Estamos a falar de milhões
de consumidores.
Enquanto tivermos a ideia
de ter a nossa lojinha
e a nossa empresa aqui
apenas vamos estar a vender
para 150, 200 mil pessoas...
eventualmente, se vierem turistas,
mais um pouco...
Agora imaginem que
nós abrimos um "marketplace",
onde nós vendemos os produtos de Guimarães
e onde toda a gente colabora,
toda a gente pode ajudar,
o que é que pode acontecer?
É a minha pergunta.
Se, em nove anos, a Prozis fez o que fez,
eu imagino
se começarmos hoje,
como será Guimarães daqui a dez anos.
E eu gostaria de estar aqui,
daqui a dez anos, para ver o resultado.
Muito obrigado!
(Aplausos)